new research raises questions about
aspirin therapy where people take daily
low doses of the drug three reports in
the New England Journal of Medicine
found that among healthy senior citizens
the death rate for those taking aspirin
was higher than for those who did not
the study also found an increased risk
of certain types of internal bleeding
among those who take the drug and no
significant cardiac benefit our dr.
David agus is in Los Angeles with more
and dr. agus a lot of people take this
preemptively a third of Americans
actually over 40 take a daily low-dose
aspirin should they stop now
bianna it's a very complicated picture
and you know one that is confusing and I
think that's why we're talking about it
this morning so first of all this is for
prevention so people who have existing
heart disease no question they should
continue their Aspin if their doctor
told them - there have been studies done
showing that in people aged 50 when you
start an aspirin there's a clear benefit
the problem is in this study was people
ages 70 and older so what are the
current recommendations for people who
should take a daily low-dose aspirin so
in this study 70 and older no benefit at
all and potentially some harm in age 50
there's a clear benefit in people who
have high risk for heart disease that's
greater than 10% chance and there's a
benefit on cancer particularly colon
cancer in that study in age 60 and above
it's really the decision of the doctor
and the patient together so the bottom
line is talk to your doctor make a
personal decision based on your age and
your risk factor this is an important
study and a well-done study and it means
is if you hadn't started in your fifth
or six decades don't start at age 70
based on these data dr. agus I've also
heard about taking a baby aspirin after
you've had a heart event people who
claim that there were there lives were
saved from that what's your guidance on
that issue 100% and so it clearly went
during chest pain take an aspirin after
a heart of M that data are clear is that
you need to continue taking an aspirin
no matter what age you are if your
doctor says it's appropriate for your
situation
so if for those between 40 and 60 who
haven't started taking a daily load
aspirin and are thinking about it should
they or should they consult their doctor
first 100% consult your doctor first and
have a discussion again the data and the
clinical trials start at age 50 and with
a significant risk of heart disease
there's a benefit and clearly there's a
benefit on cancer that you see after
taking the drug for five years and that
continues for up to 15 years so it's a
confusing area and you know the the
interesting part is when many of this
studies were done 20 30 years ago we
took less statins the lipitor like drugs
we actually smoked more and we were
smaller we've grown larger since so it's
very hard to say did they old studies
apply now or not it's a confusing area
and we're gonna get more data over the
next several years and hopefully we'll
learn more but the data are clear now
age 50 have the discussion 60 have the
discussion 70 don't I'm so glad you're
here dr. agus because even this morning
here in the newsroom and amongst the
crew talking about this some of it oh
gosh on another one of these studies I
guess I'm not supposed to be taking
aspirin and you have clarified that this
is about a specific age group and still
the overwhelming data is clear on
aspirin that it does have benefits
correct yeah the one size fits all is
really just not applicable here and so
aspirins still powerful drug but the
discussion with the doctor based on your
age of risk factor needs to happen dr.
David agus always good to see you thank
you so much